the driver of the van hit by a six pound
rock in Michigan is speaking out about
the deadly incident for the first time
Stephen and Thor says he's devastated he
could not save his friend's life
Kenneth white was killed when the rock
smashed through the windshield five high
school students are charged with second
degree murder for allegedly throwing the
rock Adriana Diaz is in Clio Michigan at
the intersection where the incident
happened
Adriana good morning good morning the
men were on this highway driving home
from work it was about 8:30 p.m. so dark
out like it is now
they were driving about 70 miles per
hour under this overpass when in an
instant their routine commute turned
into a horror scene I don't blame myself
what happened I blame myself like I
couldn't do it enough Steven amp Thor
says Kenneth White's death left him
feeling angry and numb he was driving
white his employee home after a day's
work they were talking about baseball
when a rock suddenly smashed through the
windshield less than five miles from his
house and next thing you know I'm pulled
over trying to keep him from bleeding
out then came a difficult call amthar
had to tell his own best friend White's
father that his son was dead Donald
white is the victim's uncle and he
called my brother while sitting on
silent Road in Chryse and I'm sorry I
tried to do my best and I coulda stopped
me from bleeding white was killed by a
six pound rock about five inches wide
and eight inches long allegedly dropped
from an overpass above Interstate 75
prosecutors say these five teenagers
were responsible ages 15 to 17 the high
schooler shuffled into equipment Tuesday
in Chains they could face up to life in
prison for second-degree murder all
pleaded not guilty
Frank Manley represents 16 year-old mark
sakowski what if they didn't do anything
what if they're afraid of the older kid
and they're standing there does that
make them a murderer white a 32 year old
father of four was declared dead on
arrival at the hospital one of his
children is just five years old I will
everything I can to see that his son has
taken care of he's not good to get to
grow up with a father like I did I think
that's what hurts the worst anther hopes
this case serves as a warning to other
teens he also wants the state to install
nets or gates on overpasses to prevent
another drive home from turning deadly
Charlie thanks Adriana